nach dem wochenende ist der ausgang wird
der dienst der hotline kurzen und einen
vollen schritt wieder ganz für die
angelobung
de buchen wir in 16 stunden erste hilfe
kurs und haben wir mit der theorie und
dennoch ist leider hielten mit stationen
betrieb und wie man zum beispiel videos
ist so witzig war zum beispiel werden
bergen muss aus dem auto aber natürlich
noch der kamera in echten dann
wahrscheinlich in bayern
[Musik]
und darauf hat man das kind nicht
überschritten
sehr viel
[Musik]
weitere stationen waren auch hannover
bonn darum den schülern verboten glanz
zb druckverband machen oder einen
kopfverband oder schlimmer für die hat
nichts mit erschrecken wir durch sind
irgendwann die nase als leider etwas
kurz das alles kann mit ihren
transportern wie die ducati zurzeit
einfach drehen
[Musik]